all right star
star where'd you grow up where are you
from originally uh midair
which is where
uh it's kind of by fresno sort of
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad
um yeah something like that but my
grandma used to take care of me most of
the time
why did your mom and dad not
um take care of you
not my dad so much but my mom did yeah
somewhat
but basically you just helped friend
about them
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um
i feel like
my childhood they just
sent me to
[ __ ]
i'm kind of sorry
but they kind of just
i feel like they helped me at the same
time
they kind of like tore me down but
it wasn't their fault i felt like it was
other people's fault but they just
didn't know so
that's that's not their fault
was there drugs in their life or they
were young um no my mom my mom was sober
but my grandma she did have a problem
but she got sober by like the time i was
born so i don't think it was issue for
me
[Music]
you made it through high school
oh no
you dropped out uh yeah i did
how far did you go
uh all the way to 11
yeah
and then you started this kind of work
after that uh something like that yeah
kind of
did you work with a pimp or on your own
no i've always kind of been alone you
know
i don't really like
that overpowerment i think that's like
my biggest issue like i never like
people telling me what to do
hate that [ __ ]
i don't blame you
so you keep your money
oh yeah yeah but i always put it up like
girls out here be walking around with
their money on them like just the other
night i got like
scuffled up i guess you could say like a
dude he thought that i had like money on
me and he was like oh you know like come
with me and i was like oh [ __ ] and then
boom got stuck up and he's like where'd
money have itch and
yeah see i arrived
yeah for my chain
that's about it
i have no money on me
i don't do that how old are you right
now i'm 20 20. yeah
and do you have kids or anything
no kids
that's what i'm saying i never really
liked like people telling me what to do
i feel like if i had a kid then i would
just have like so many different
perspectives of people trying to tell me
like what should i do as a mom and [ __ ]
and i feel like that's out
plus i don't need kids i'm young yeah
it's a good attitude
so your your plan is to do this for a
short time and
basically get out
it's not forever shouldn't be forever
what would you like to do
um
it probably sounds crazy but i am finna
move up out of california i'm probably
gonna go to like vegas
or dallas or something like that
start working like um with animals and
[ __ ] like that because that's what i was
doing before working up on that so i'm
probably just gonna go back yeah
and you started this work in oakland or
where
stockton started yeah
pretty much
rough and starfleet
it's a lot of crazy [ __ ] going out there
and it's always hot like not physically
hot but like hot with the police and
[ __ ]
and you've been in l.a how long oh i
don't like coming to la the last time i
came to l.a it was terrible this time
it's another [ __ ] story so you're
just here temporarily yeah
i've been going back and forth well i
see
how does la compared to
you go back and forth between here in
stockton yeah uh ellie's [ __ ] crazy
literally and i would rather be in
stockton i feel like the only thing i
like about la is that it's fast
sometimes it can be a little bit too
fast can you make more money here
[ __ ] um
i feel like it's slow but it's better
out in the bay area but yeah you do make
money in l.a
just gotta be at the right part
how does this kind of work affect you
emotionally
um
as a girl i feel like
this [ __ ] is not easy at all you know
like walking down the street and men
calling you all types of names and [ __ ]
shit's not cool you know it may degrade
other females or boost other females um
emotions and [ __ ] like that but me i
don't think so no i it's
back and forth like the other day i was
like oh you know it's a cool day and
then the next moment you know i'm having
a breakdown i don't know why
but
i feel like that's just feelings in
general
are drugs a part of your life
um i smoke weed weed helps that's it
yeah
um
i used to pop pills when i would work
but that [ __ ] is no help
it wastes your money like
it's cool off it now now i just smoke
weed so we
you guys started doing this kind of work
at what age uh young like
16 17 16.
you remember the first time you
you picked up a guy
um a guy picked you up
[ __ ] to be real no
i don't remember but i do remember like
i made like a cool little amount that
night i was happy with myself
i think that's what told me like oh you
know like this [ __ ] ain't that bad maybe
i should just keep going
what's your ideal
kind of trick
the best kind of job
[ __ ]
just if i could break them give them to
me
pretty much
you just gotta be able to sweet talk
them
so i could give you more basically like
you gotta know like what type of guy
they are like what they do and don't
like and
50 50 you're gonna get more than
they offered
by asking him for this or
yeah like you could tell a guy like oh
yeah i'll do you right now for 120 and
then you get to the room and you're
sweet talking to him and then boom the
next moment you got 300 400
type [ __ ]
how much do you typically make in a
night
it's fair
it's fair yeah
um so
is doing this kind of work change the
way you see men
um
i feel like it's a bad thing to think
that all men are bad but i feel like
whenever i am with the man even if i'm
told like oh you're safe here you're
okay i just still see like
bad
like i watched this movie before i
forgot what it was called but basically
it was like
energy you know
like white light and black type [ __ ]
and whenever it would be like guys doing
drugs or like trying to rob somebody
there would be a black light
but whenever it was somebody like going
doing good deeds it would be a white
light so it's like
i don't know i feel like
i'm not gonna say all men but certain
men with that type of vibe do have that
black light over them
and not every man has that white light
and if they do have that white light
you're a good [ __ ] person
you believe in karma
yeah i'm very spiritual i believe in
that a lot how does karma play into this
lifestyle um for you
[ __ ] i feel like
if you
if you
are good to other people then other
people will be good to you
and the universe will bring you back
gifts
it doesn't matter whether it's money or
a new friend
a better day more money
the universe they will help you and they
will send you gifts
kind of like a little god yeah does your
family know you're doing this
um
[ __ ] i would like to say not my mom my
grandma but i do have sisters
that know and cousins
so yeah no i i haven't told them pretty
much like
she asked me where i'm going or what i'm
gonna do or i'm just telling her you
know i'm going downtown type [ __ ]
the dear friends
um
friends aren't essential so no
i have my right hand which is marie
pretty much that's all
what kind of
requests do you get from your guys and
the tricks do you get them asking you to
do without a condom and stuff like that
yeah they were asking weird [ __ ] like oh
can i eat this can i eat that you want
to suck this can't take the condom off
i'm like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
y'all like y'all come out here and
you're expecting like there are girls
there or girls i'm not gonna lie that's
why men out here feel like it's the okay
to ask women like oh it's okay if i
do this to you or do that to you because
other women are actually telling these
men yes and other women like me or any
other woman that's not okay with that
[ __ ] we're like what the [ __ ] like no
that's not cool type [ __ ]
my man they'll ask like oh kai eat your
ass guy eat your vagina or
can i take the condom off can i kiss you
and i'm like
no
that's not cool
have you been in love before
um
[ __ ]
it's a strong word
but
i feel like love will come when you're
supposed to
i have an idea like i have a boyfriend
right now like i feel like i love him
but i don't know if it's really true yet
you know
you've had bad experiences out there
bad experiences oh yeah i got robbed and
beat up a couple of times
a shitty day but i got away and still
alive
was the best example of a loving
relationship you saw as a young girl
between a man and a woman
um your mom and dad
no um to be honest i never really saw a
lot of like man and woman relationship
that was good i grew up around a lot of
gay women i'm not gonna lie so yeah
everything that i saw like as a kid was
always like girls together so you know
that's what i grew up into liking girls
and dating girls like that so that's
what i saw was school like my grandma
she had an issue with it she'd be like
oh you know women it's for men and women
is not for women type [ __ ] but i didn't
care i still like girls so to stay
what's the hardest part of this kind of
work for
you trust
it will take a lot of trust
and it has to be very quick
for you to trust a man with your life
driving
parking being at your hotel you got
gotta trust that this [ __ ] won't come
back on some weird [ __ ] trying to rob
you or that he's on drugs he's gonna
stalk you so yes there's a lot of trust
and you have to be quick and think quick
too
your intuition is probably a
great tool right
very much
it's a nutty lifestyle that you're
involved with all these people that are
up to no good between the johns and the
pimps and the even the cops sometimes oh
yeah of course that's i feel like
regular people like that's not an issue
with me like i could literally
you know i'm not gonna say what i can do
but i can protect myself from all these
other people now cops that's a little
different story i've never like really
got caught up with the police like
police come it's either just run down
the other block or hide under a car
type [ __ ]
you feel like you deserve a better life
than this life you're living is
um
i feel like everybody has
a reason why they do things
and i do mine just because that's how i
make my money that's how i do my life
and
i feel like everybody could do better
and start what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
the most important lesson
um
even if somebody says
that they're your friend or they care
about you
it's not always true
you know
not everybody has
the right mindset
or
[ __ ] what's the word not everybody has
the
mentality to think right all the time
and you don't know what everybody's
intentions that's the word you don't
know what everybody's intentions are
so you should watch out for people that
are so called your friends or tell you
that they love you because that's not
always true they could just be in your
life because they know you got money and
you're going to help them out
that [ __ ] is real
[ __ ] will use you and dry you
up dry until you don't got [ __ ] left and
use you
and leave you
all right star thank you so much for
sharing your story
all right i wish you the best of luck
out there
you